Independence Day: Resurgence was supposed
to kickstart a whole new franchise in 2016,
but a third movie hasn't materialized since
then - and it likely never will.
Here's why the Independence Day series is
finished for good.
While boasting an ensemble cast of familiar
faces like Jeff Goldblum and Bill Pullman,
the breakout star of Independence Day was
Will Smith.
"Welcome to Earth."
Up to that point, Smith was best known for
his recording career and TV's Fresh Prince
of Bel-Air, but this movie established him
as a bona fide movie star.
For years afterwards, Smith virtually owned
Independence Day weekend at the box office,
starring in a string of early July blockbusters
that included Men in Black, Bad Boys II, and
Hancock.
By the time Independence Day: Resurgence began
production nearly 20 years later, Smith was
too busy to return to the franchise that helped
make him such a screen idol.
"I had a couple of films lined up, I had Concussion
and Suicide Squad, and so it was a decision,
timing-wise, between Independence Day and
Suicide Squad."
In retrospect, that was kind of a no-win scenario.
Resurgence's screenwriters revised the film's
script to explain the absence of Smith's character,
Captain Steven Hiller, killing him off screen
before the events of the sequel.
That creative decision effectively precludes
Smith from returning for any future movies,
and without its biggest, most bankable star,
why keep the franchise going?
"Y'all take care, all right?
Nothin' but love for you."
When a movie makes a ton of money at the box
office, it makes sense to make a sequel in
a hurry, while audiences' fond memories of
the movie are fresh.
This didn't happen with Independence Day.
The first film was the top grosser of 1996,
raking in $306 million.
But the sequel hit theaters in 2016, a full
20 years later, barely clearing $100 million
at the American box office against a reported
production cost of $165 million.
Making things worse, the people that saw Resurgence
generally didn't care for it.
It amassed a Rotten Tomatoes audience score
of just 30 percent, slightly better than its
29 percent rating from critics.
A review in Entertainment Weekly gave the
film an "F," calling it, quote, "disposable
and shockingly inept."
In the end, Fox lost too much money and audience
goodwill on Resurgence to proceed with a sequel,
getting the message that people weren't interested.
The original Independence Day is full of talented
actors, but aside from Will Smith, it's not
exactly a roster of movie stars.
Actors like Bill Pullman, Randy Quaid, Brent
Spiner, and Vivica A. Fox make for a deep
bench in these movies' casts, but on their
own, none of them can really carry a big-budget
sci-fi extravaganza - not even Jeff Goldblum.
"...We never had a chance."
While they make for a strong ensemble in the
original movie, these actors have mostly faded
from the limelight since the first Independence
Day was released.
The new young additions to the cast also failed
to fill the gap in star power - including
Liam Hemsworth, best known for his supporting
work in The Hunger Games, and for being related
to Thor.
Unless the producers wanted to make the third
movie a full reboot, that's the cast the movie
would have to work with, and as the box office
returns for Resurgence make clear, audiences
aren't eager to show up to see them.
With or without the original cast, another
movie would be a big risk.
Independence Day came to fruition thanks to
a team up between filmmakers Dean Devlin and
Roland Emmerich.
The duo co-wrote the script, with Devlin producing
and Emmerich directing.
Both returned for Resurgence, but it doesn't
look like that will happen again - at least
not for Devlin.
During an appearance at WonderCon in 2018,
the filmmaker was quoted as saying,
"Currently, I personally have no plans on
doing another one."
A few weeks later, he solidified his departure
on The Matthew Aaron Show podcast, saying
he was backing away from working with major
studios after the failure of the 2017 movie
Geostorm.
As a result, he excused himself from both
more Independence Day and a reboot of his
other big franchise, Stargate.
With one of the chief minds behind the movies
now out of the running, the future of Independence
Day seems unstable, if not nonexistent.
The first two Independence Day films were
productions from Twentieth Century Fox - a
studio which was swallowed up in a $71.3 billion
acquisition by Disney in early 2019.
That means Disney is now calling the shots
behind the scenes, in total control of that
studio's old franchises, including Avatar,
Deadpool, and Independence Day.
Two of those are billion-dollar franchises,
and one… isn't.
According to The Wall Street Journal, the
new bosses are significantly ramping down
Fox's movie production, especially when it
comes to expensive projects that aren't family-friendly
or guaranteed franchise builders.
That spells bad news for another visit to
this particular well.
Disney's having a hard enough time keeping
interest in Star Wars going, and that's one
of the most popular franchises of all time.
Do you really think they're going to sink
any work into a risky third installment of
the Independence Day series?
In the absence of viewers demanding it, it
looks like there's no chance.
"We will not go quietly into the night!
We will not vanish without a fight!
We're going to live on!
We're going to survive!"
Yeah… actually?
Maybe not.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.